WE KNOW WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN
HE'S ANGRY.
HE IS CLEARLY NOT ANGRY ABOUT
THIS.
>> Bret: WE WILL FOLLOW UP
ABOUT WHAT SARAH SANDERS WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
AN UPDATE ON OUR FAVORITE
PANELIST.
I HAVE UPDATED YOU ABOUT THE
HEALTH AND STATUS OF
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER.
OF THE QUESTIONS I GET ON EMAIL
AND TWITTER AND FACEBOOK, HOW IS
CHARLES?
IT TOPS THE LIST.
CHARLES HAS BEEN RECOVERING FROM
COMPLICATIONS AFTER A SURGERY
FOR SEVERAL MONTHS.
I CHECK IN WITH CHARLES MORE
THAN I TELL YOU.
A LOT.
TODAY HE HAD A MESSAGE HE WANTED
ME TO SHARE WITH YOU, THE
VIEWERS OF "SPECIAL REPORT."
"THINGS ARE PROGRESSING STEADILY
SLOWER THAN I WOULD LIKE BUT
STEADILY.
STILL I WISH I COULD GIVE YOU
AND MYSELF A BETTER IDEA OF WHEN
THIS MARATHON ENDS.
I AM SURE IT IS STRANGE FOR YOUR
VIEWERS THAT A REGULAR PANELIST
SHOULD DISAPPEAR FOR MONTHS
WITHOUT WARNING AND WITHOUT ANY
REAL EXPLANATION.
THERE WERE SERIOUS COMPLICATIONS
AFTER MY SURGERY.
MY IMPROVEMENT HAS FINALLY
ALLOWED ME TO CONCENTRATE ON
INTENSIVE REHABILITATION TO
RECOVER MY STRENGTH AND STAMINA.
THIS TOO IS PROGRESSING WELL BUT
IS INTENSE AND SLOW.
NONETHELESS, I AM DETERMINED TO
MAKE IT BACK.
I'VE GOT TO.
I CAN'T LET YOU GUYS HAVE ALL
THE FUN."
CHARLES, WE MISS YOU AND YOUR
VOICE ON THE BIG ISSUES FACING